what's the relationship between this and
the original cosine graph it's the same
graph it upside down which is a little
bit weird
what we've done is we've moved
horizontally but the effect has been a
reflection this is actually this is
actually something we're about to get to
but I don't have enough space on the
board this identity that cause X minus
180 is always minus cos x this is
something we're going to explore a
little bit later when we look at the
double
compound angle results but this has been
shifted interestingly I still have these
intercepts Y intercepts unchanged
because that's where the intercepts
usually aren't the cause I haven't
actually gone all the way to get a full
copy right because the shift is only
half of the period but think about this
you know what the period is is 360 how
often do you get roots how frequently do
they happen like I've got one at ninety
I've got one to Sony what's the next one
that hard to work out pretty sure that
next one would be at 450 right 450 would
be there the next one after that is
going to be at 630 the roots happen
every 180 degrees don't they which is
why between 1 to 60 you have exactly two
of them well if the roots happen every
180 degrees then if you go forward 180
degrees then they still happen all
exactly the same spots does that make
sense so that's why the values are
unchanged
now before I wipe off what's on the
board we said a horizontal stretch has a
special name for a trig function and the
vertical stretch also has a special name
the horizontal shift gets a special name
to come
we call this the phase this is a word
that I alluded to last week actually
right because sine and cosine are only
off by a horizontal shift they are out
of phase with each other so when you
hear the word face you need to be able
to recognize what their meaning is I've
moved left or right so now last little
thing on is question your still listen
to the radio because like with Spotify
and stuff I don't know people still yeah
what are you what station is debating
this is it 90 seats for one you know 109
for nine anyone I'm 104 wait too old
okay radio stations that moist those
listen to you right are actually not
just the number like say what are we
just saying 96.9 okay
what they really are called is I have a
90 super 9 FM or they put the FM out the
front sometimes does anyone know what
the f in FM stands for it stands for
frequency right now FM's not the only
kind of rigor that you can reach you can
also reach a breaker does anyone know
what the page there's always tense for
empathy right because all of the radio
waves that are coming to our little
receivers in fact all the ways right
there were all sines and cosines
every single one something for
combination of them so what if that
radio is doing is it's listening and
when the frequency of that signal
changes it interprets that as a
different sound whereas if you switch
your right ear over to a
it then starts the sitting for something
else it doesn't start listening for how
the up and down changes sorry it doesn't
start listening for how the frequency
changes it's not listening for how big
this difference is right which is why if
you ever listen to an AM radio the
quality is quite poor because the
further you go away the weak of the
signal gets this just naturally gets
smaller and smaller because that's the
way energy works the further it goes the
more it does that so that's what that's
talking about and that's why I am
indifferent radios over to you okay okay
another flash minute is one kind of
change left that I haven't talked about
we've done stretching we've done
shifting I actually allude to it in the
very last graph that we did which is why
it's what I chose there's another way I
can change things that doesn't have to
do with squeezing and squashing or
shifting around what would you call this
if I husband graphic that instead you
get the same picture but you wouldn't
have said that what I've ended up with
is a horizontal shift what would you
call that
now lots of lots of words here I know
it's somewhat confusing to mix them all
together what you've really done if I
ask you to do this is a reflection feel
great yeah you can reflect these lots of
different ways for example just have a
look at this back for a second now I can
reflect this the same way I've reflected
this right I'm gonna do it right now oh
yeah I flip that upside down do you
agree this it's now the top it used to
be at the bottom right so I've gone
across that axis so that was the shift
that I sorry that was the reflection
idea being that I moved it like this
what kind of reflection would you call
that look I've got two kinds of
everything on the board which is this
one
[Music]
now all I would probably tend to call
this a vertical reflection because the
reflection is happening up and down
right everything that used to be down is
now up everything that you just threw up
is now down so I would call that a very
cool reflection which then begs the
question well what's the other case it's
horizontal so I don't do this I do this
right you see these strings that are at
the top when I flip reflect horizontally
the streets stay at the top
do you agree okay so what that means is
when you have a look at this now this is
a vertical reflection so which variable
is it changing X or Y it's vertical
right I'm actually changing the Y's
which is why I'm gonna suggest why I'm
gonna suggest these wipers - plus X is
not a helpful way to write what's going
on do you see how it would be more
instructive really it's minus y equals
code X because what are you mucking
around with you're mucking around with
the up and down the vertical okay so if
you then wanted to change things that
way where would you put the minus sign
you wouldn't attach it to the Y you'd
attach it to the X so for example if I
wanted to change any of these guys up
here I could do sine of minus X that's
going to look like the regular sine
graph but I'm gonna go like this and
reflect if I do this I'm gonna take the
regular cosine graph and then I'm going
to reflect it like this does that make
sense